bonsoir michel pour les commerces
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct sur
rt france nouveau coup dur pour le
secteur aérien et pour air france qui
souffre déjà beaucoup de la pandémie
cette suppression des vols accessible
donc en train de moins de 2h30
clairement est-ce que air france
traverse telle une crise inédite
alors oui en france traverse mais c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui
une crise importante et notamment air
france depuis plusieurs années
perdez beaucoup d'argent sur ses lignes
régionales ce qui explique qu'avec la
situation créée par le cos vide
d'un côté le gouvernement a voulu aider
air france en lui donnant de l'argent et
de l'autre côté comme il fallait des
contreparties eh bien on a décidé de lui
interdire de poursuivre la couverture
des lignes sur lesquelles elles
perdaient de l'argent donc notamment
comme elle perdait de l'argent sur paris
lyon paris nantes paris bordeaux et
qu'elles n'avaient pas de clientèle
intéressante sur lyon marseille et bien
on a décrété que air france ne pourrait
plus assurer ses vignes et évidemment
pour être sûr que ça rapporte quand même
pas de l'argent à d'autres qui sait plus
débrouillards et bien on a décidé que ce
serait interdit à tout le monde
donc oui air france est en situation
relativement difficile comme toutes les
compagnies aériennes
elle est en situation plus difficile que
les autres évidemment sur son propre
territoire sur le territoire français
est actuellement en prenant les
décisions qui ont été prises avec la loi
climat en fait quelque part on
intervient dans un système économique
qu'on ne sait pas très bien maîtrisée
dont on ne connaît pas parfaitement les
réelles économies sur le gaz à effet de
serre et dont on ne connaît pas non plus
réellement les conséquences en terme
d'économie pour le transport aérien et
d'économie pour l'emploi michel polacco
quand vous nous dites à risques on sait
effectivement que air france perdait de
l'argent sur ses lignes intérieures est
ce que d'une certaine manière
cette loi votée à l'initiative des
écologistes n'est pas si grave pour la
compagnie non pour la compagnie air
france très honnêtement les pas grave
puisque air france va pouvoir continuer
à assurer les lignes entre charles de
gaulle c'est à dire roissy où elle a ses
correspondances et les villes de
bordeaux de lyon de marseille etc de
toulouse de nantes et en même temps elle
va donc arrêter les lignes qui sur ces
destinations aller vers orly sur
lesquelles elles perdaient de l'argent
vont pourrir france ça n'a rien d'une
catastrophe
est ce que les écologistes se serait
peut-être là le danger vont s'en tenir
là on entend ici ou là des grands débats
sur les quotas de long-courriers par
exemple est ce que l'on tant que
spécialiste de l'aérien
c'est à craindre écoutez suis un peu
inquiet c'est vrai parce que il y as
chez les verts des gens qui ont des
raisonnements on va appeler raisonnable
qui sont capables de réfléchir dans le
temps à la manière qu'il est nécessaire
d'appliquer pour que le transport aérien
apporte son écot à l'économie de rejet
dans l'atmosphère mais il y en a qui
sont quand même des intégristes et qui
se rendent pas compte qu'il faut du
temps cela dit n'oublions pas que le
transport aérien tous les 20 ans divisé
par deux ses rejets de gaz à effet de
serre ces rejets de carbone que donc le
transport aérien est déjà un outil très
sage et il s'est engagé à arriver à zéro
rezé en 2050 comme d'ailleurs certains
aéroports sont déjà arrivés à zéro rejet
comme nice cannes saint-tropez enfin il
ya quatre aéroports en france qui sont
déjà arrivés à zéro rejet
donc si vous voulez si on laisse les
entreprises et les compagnies avec des
consignes mais si on les laisse se
débrouiller
elles vont y arriver
se fera de manière raisonnable en accord
avec l'industrie et donc ça permettra
sans doute de ne pas avoir de
conséquence néfaste pour l'emploi et
pour la compétitivité internationale des
constructeurs et des compagnies
françaises et européennes si en revanche
on poursuit dans un système très
directif très idéologique est très
pressé eh bien je pense que on va faire
des erreurs des fautes et que finalement
on aura certainement pas les résultats
escomptés
pourtant le secteur aérien représente
3,5 pour cent de l'empreinte carbone
totale du pays
c'est une goutte d'eau selon vous est-ce
que ça ça justifie pas cet acharnement
enfin voilà sept as et rien bashing non
c'est pas une goutte d'eau il est très
bien de prendre en compte le climat et
les rejets dans l'atmosphère
encore une fois prenez les avions 1958
quand vous les voyez décoller il y avait
une grosse traînée noir derrière et
essayer prouver les traces d'un avion
moderne qui décolle aujourd'hui comme un
airbus 350 où un boeing 787 qui part de
roissy ou d'orly il y en a plus c'est
fini donc si vous voulez tout le monde
fait des efforts et tout le monde fait
de très sérieuses et fort maintenant
entre faire des efforts et être
contraint à faire faillite il ya quand
même une différence
il ne faut pas tuer nos entreprises si
on tue nos entreprises ce sont des
entreprises étrangères qui prendront le
relais et puis il ya quand même aussi
une chose qu'il faut dire c'est qu'on ne
peut pas remplacer l'avion par le train
partout on a supprimé presque toutes les
petites lignes régionales de train
il reste quelques ter mais il ya
beaucoup de lignes régionales qui ont
été supprimés il ya des horaires de tgv
ou de train rapide qui sont très
limitées et souvent très mal commode je
prends axé sur bordeaux ou sur nantes
qu' il y à un seul train par jour
danser sur rennes il ya un seul train
par jour à 16h44 qui met deux heures
trente de tous les autres trains met
beaucoup plus que deux heures et demie
donc si on dit qu'on supprime les trains
fallait les avions qui sont à moins 2
heure et demie 30 baril eh bien on va
faire des bêtises
c'est pas sérieux les gens peuvent pas
avoir un seul moyen de transport par
jour pour aller prendre une
correspondance à charles de gaulle ou à
orly pour aller quelque part en europe
dans le monde
il faut tenir compte des besoins des
gens qui se déplacent qui peuvent être
des besoins de loisirs qui peuvent être
des besoins professionnels et il faut
arrêter de faire de l'économie dirigé
qui devient pire que l'économie
soviétique alors peut-être une lueur au
bout de la piste
si j'ose dire concernant cette crise
évidemment du secteur aérien dans le
cadre cette fois de la pandémie le
passeport sanitaire est ce que pour vous
c'est c'est un bon espoir justement pour
pour le secteur c'est de là que viendra
le salut je pense que c'est raisonnable
tous nous pensons que c'est désagréable
de rajouter des papiers aux papiers des
contrôles au contrôle des contraintes
aux contraintes
ça nous fait pas plaisir mais il est
vrai que si on a envie que le système
retrouve un peu de fluidité et puisse
redémarrer raisonnablement c'est à dire
pas trop lentement
l'idée du passeport vaccinale est
quelque chose qui est assez intelligent
effectivement et puis après tout ceux
qui ne veulent pas s'y soumettent ne
sont pas obligés de s'y soumettre
ils pourront toujours renoncé à se
déplacer ou se déplacer en fournissant
des tests etc
merci à michel polacco rappel vous êtes
journée spéciale d'essais aéronautiques
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france ce soir